bienvenidos a reglas de los exponentes
en nivel 1 parte 2 para resumir lo que
hemos estado trabajando en el vídeo
anterior y de las reglas de los
exponentes podríamos decir que si yo
tengo 2 a la 10 que es x 2 a las 5
habíamos dicho que en los casos que yo
tengo números con exponentes con la
misma base entonces los exponentes se
suman o sea esto es lo mismo que 2 a la
10 más 5 y esto es igual a 2 a la 15
luego también estábamos viendo este otro
caso que es el que pasa si yo tengo 2 a
la 10 que está siendo dividido por 2 a
las 5
bueno pues en este caso habíamos dicho
que se restan los exponentes y entonces
esto es lo mismo que tener dos a la diez
menos cinco que es igual a 2 a la 5
y luego aunque creo que lo presente de
una manera un poco rápida en el vídeo
anterior y ahora habrá que hacerlo con
más detenimiento y más atención en
teníamos este otro caso que es el que
pasa si tengo 2 a la 10 y todo esto está
siendo elevado a la quinta potencia a la
entonces este en este caso veamos con
calma o sea qué quiere decir cuando yo
elevó a una potencia algo bueno pues es
cuestión de reescribir esto es lo mismo
que tener 2 a la 10
2 a la 10
obs este no me gustó eso 2 a la 10 por 2
a la 10 me falta uno por 2 a la 10
y entonces regresamos a nuestra primera
regla de los exponentes que es cuando un
número con exponentes con la misma base
se está multiplicando y entonces se
suman los exponentes y quien tenemos
aquí pues es
10 10 son 20 más 10 son 30 más 10 un 40
más 10 son 50 y esto me da como
resultado 2 a las 50
que entonces esta nueva tercera regla
para los exponentes la podemos decir de
esta manera cuando yo tengo un número
con un exponente que a su vez está
siendo elevado a otro exponente entonces
los exponentes se multiplican o sea que
este 50 que tengo aquí es lo mismo que
multiplicar 10 por 5 vamos a ver otro
ejemplo el que pasa si yo tengo 3 a la
séptima que está siendo elevado a la
menos 9 entonces otra vez es cuestión de
multiplicar los exponentes entonces me
va a quedar 3 7 por nueve es 63 pero
como es negativo me queda menos 63 osea
esto funciona también con exponentes
negativos
y ahora vamos a ver otras propiedades de
los exponentes a ver voy a borrar esto
entonces lo siguiente que te voy a
enseñar ahora es esto
qué está aquí mira qué pasa si yo tengo
2 que estamos explicando a 9
9 y todo esto se encuentra a la 100
a la potencia 100 bueno entonces esto lo
que vamos a mostrar que esto va a ser
igual a 2 a las 100 que multiplica a 9 a
las 100 vamos a demostrarlo con un
ejemplo más sencillo por ejemplo si yo
tengo este que está aquí es 4 x 5
a la tercera potencia o al cubo esto
simplemente lo que me dice si yo tengo
algo a la tercera potencia entonces lo
que tengo es esto es 4 por 5
que multiplica a 4 por 5 marcar más para
que se note bien que es multiplicación
eso
esto que está multiplicando a 4 por 5 es
la definición no si yo tengo algo a la
tercera potencia es eso mismo
multiplicado tres veces pero ahora lo
voy a reescribir o sea que esto mismo es
lo reescribiendo reacomodando los
términos ahora lo que puedo describirlo
como 4 por 4 por 4 1 que aparece tres
veces el 4 que está multiplicando a 5
por 5 por 5 y aquí lo único que hice fue
reacomodar los términos y para poderlo
escribir de esta manera entonces cuatro
por cuatro por cuatro
pues eso simplemente es 4 al cubo y 5
por 5 por 5 pues simplemente es 5 a la
tercer potencia o alcohol
entonces efectivamente cuatro por cinco
a la tercer potencia es lo que tenemos
de este lado y entonces el ejemplo con
el que empezamos ahora podemos ver que
esto que está aquí es igual a esto que
está acá
y de esta manera hemos demostrado que se
cumple esta propiedad a veces a mí se me
olvidan las reglas de los exponentes y
lo que hago es volver a construirlas
esta es una forma de recordarlas y en
general las las demostraciones pues se
pueden construir para demostrar las
ahora lo que voy a hacer es resumir todo
lo que hemos estado haciendo bueno pues
como dije ahora vamos a resumir todo lo
que hemos estado haciendo y entonces
vamos a enumerar nuestras reglas de los
exponentes o sean yo dije que si tengo
dos a las siete que está siendo
multiplicado por dos a la tercer
potencia entonces cómo es multiplicación
con la misma base esto simplemente se
suman los exponentes y esto me queda 2 a
la 10
y luego dijimos que si yo tengo dos a
las siete que está siendo dividido entre
dos a la tres en el caso de la división
de números con exponentes con la misma
base los exponentes se restan y esto me
va a quedar igual a dos a las siete
menos tres que es cuatro luego también
habíamos mencionado que en este caso que
si yo tengo el que si yo tengo dos a las
siete y todo esto está siendo elevado a
la tercer potencia entonces para el caso
de un número con un exponente que está
siendo elevado a otro exponente dijimos
que los exponentes se multiplican y esto
va a terminar siendo 2 que es la base 7
por 3 21 son nuestros exponentes a la 21
potencia a la 21 potencia y finalmente
teníamos este otro caso que decía en el
caso de la multiplicación de dos números
yo tengo todos por siete y todo esto
está siendo elevado a la tercera
potencia esto va a ser 2 al cubo por 7
al cubo de acuerdo esto es todo lo que
habíamos dicho y ahora vamos a ponerlo
en práctica con este pequeño ejercicio
que vamos a hacer entonces
el ejercicio que vamos a hacer
va a ser el siguiente va a ser que yo
tengo 3 al cuadrado 3 a la segunda
potencia que está multiplicando y vamos
a poner este vídeo sale que sea 9 a la
octava potencia que no me gustó mucho
este avergonzado
aunque está mejor 9 a la octava potencia
y todo esto
este elevado a la menos 2
entonces lo primero que estamos
observando es que nuestros números no
tienen la misma base o sea 1 estrés el
otro es 9 pero si soy un poco más
observador puedo ver que el 9 lo puedo
escribir en términos de 3 o sea
3 es múltiplo de perdón el 3 es un
múltiplo en el 9 entonces vamos a
reescribir lo de esta manera este va a
ser nuestro primer paso o sea yo puedo
escribirlo 3 al cuadrado multiplicado
por 3 al cuadrado si observas 3 al
cuadrado es 9 que está elevado a la
octava a la 8 y todo esto a la menos 2
aquí no hice nada más que reescribir el
9 de otra manera en términos del 3 y así
tengo en la misma base en ambos en ambos
casos bueno pero entonces ahora
observando lo que tenemos aquí podemos
aplicar lo que sabemos para las
potencias que es esto que está aquí sí y
entonces esto lo puedo reescribir ahora
como 3 al cuadrado que está
multiplicando a 3 y en utilizando esta
tercera regla que enumeramos ahora tengo
dos por 8 16 esto es lo mismo si que 3
la potencia 16 y todo a la menos 2 y
entonces ahora puede identificar que ya
tengo dos números con exponentes con la
misma base y entonces puedo aplicar la
regla del producto que es esta que está
acá y entonces ahora sumo los exponentes
y esto va a ser simplemente 2
más 16 es 18 hace 3 a la 18 que todo
está haciendo elevado a la menos 2 y
entonces ahora es el momento de aplicar
otra vez esta misma regla que tenemos
aquí sí y entonces 18 x menos 2 es menos
36 y entonces me va a quedar 3
al menos 36 lo importante de las reglas
de los exponentes es que sepas
reconstruirlas y tal vez si quieres
aprender telas bueno pues ese es un
camino es la decisión es tuya yo
preferiría
y que aprendas a demostrar las a llegar
a ellas y porque eso te va a permitir en
cualquier momento de tu vida aun cuando
no las uses muy frecuentemente y pues
recordarlas si tú tienes los elementos
para reconstruir las que son estas que
tenemos del lado izquierdo en fin
en los siguientes ejercicios en la
sección de nivel 1 bueno no van a ser de
esta complejidad van a ser más sencillos
y ya para las reglas de exponentes vamos
a hacer ejercicios de esta complejidad
muy similares al que acabamos de hacer y
pues en fin yo te invito a que sigas
practicando y en especial a que aprendas
tú a reconstruir las reglas de los
exponentes
bueno pues diviértete y nos vemos en el
próximo